all right let's look at a couple other
interesting Clips there was an event
with Christian supporters of Republican
Senate candidate Herschel Walker now
Herschel Walker claims to be pro-life he
claims that abortion is murder he claims
no exceptions for the woman whether it's
rape incest or health or no no
exceptions ever
and he has now been credibly accused of
urging and paying for an abortion for a
woman
uh with whom he allegedly already had
another child and the right Wingers and
the Christians you would think that they
would say wow well this guy really isn't
for us instead they held a prayer for
Herschel and his wife they apparently
believe that these attacks are coming
from the devil they rebuke the devil
this is utter Insanity take a look at
this
amen we call forth your ministering
angels
and we ask you to rebuke the devil it's
the devil's fault not Herschel walkers
Satan will not hit the victory we know
whatever the results of this election
Herschel wins right he's a winner
hey you know maybe if these values are
so important to you Christian supporters
of Herschel Walker maybe focus on the
fact that he lied to you about his view
on abortion rather than blaming the
devil so we thank you that we can
support our fellow conqueror and our
brother and our friends the one that we
are praying for today we lift up his
wife
amenities
[Music]
this is this is not a satire this is
real I hope people understand let's find
her with spiritual resolve yes a
backbone of Holy Ghost steel
faith will be stronger than it's ever
been before so they have renewed faith
in Herschel Walker these are
hypocritians hypocritical Christians
this wasn't the work of the devil this
was Herschel Walker's own doing and
Herschel Walker's own lying and
dishonestly and by the way praying for
the guy after we learned not only about
this entire abortion Fiasco but his
ex-wife and son had to move six times in
six years due to the alleged acts of
domestic violence from Herschel Walker
against his family and they're praying
for Herschel what's Christian about that
and again only if you're so deluded and
also by the way willing to suspend
disbelief in a way where you say none of
this stuff is true what's true is that
the devil Satan apparently sent by
democrats Democrats have Satan on a
hotline apparently send him in anytime
that's who's to blame here this really
is sort of like the cherry on top where
there is no reasoning with these people
now why do I think the polling continues
to shift away from Walker if his
supporters are like this they're not all
like this there are more casual
Republicans in Georgia who they don't
like Warnock but after this they're not
going to vote for Walker Independence as
well and that's why I believe that the
next round of polling that we get will
probably know it by Monday Tuesday after
the the Monday holiday I believe that
Walker will be even more underwater than
he already is